tony brothers josh chivin our referees
the ultimate billy kennedy and powell is
on top
game six won by dallas eighteen is on
doncic
shot clock is down to eight
[Applause]
and the ball is going to be in lucas now
80 to 85 percent of the time here's the
step up by luca and english out there
and luca trains it t and up from three
hard to believe a week ago the sun's led
this series two games to none
branch it's three god wow
cleveland
and that's the problem are you either
you're going to switch with ayden or
you're not
and it's intercepted by dorian finney
smith the other way with numbers
punching on the wing booker comes out on
vinnie smith and dodge goes right back
bridges
the walk in the corner eight is there
bullock had a big game six with his
defense in his scoring cranston was
knocked off balance puffed up the ball
crowded picked off by
[Applause]
spencer dinwiddie with the big shot
they got him in the porzingis trade and
he hits right there for the mavs message
with the ball finney smith in the corner
for toms is in for the first time for
the mavs
how about the pass though by luca
three assists as well
cam johnson
working him down low downtrends with the
bump in the street another two and he's
got 12. oh and he's having work here we
go again congratulations
[Applause]
big smile 19 points
look about the fade away here by luca
he's backing down their center
six of eight eighteen points four or
five from downtown here's the switch
don just was sixteen
in the biambo
inside give him 18. so forcing him to go
left and just picking apart every single
thing about his game that gives him
comfort
what a hard shot
defended by cam johnson puts him under a
minute to go here in the first half
stunning 27 point lead down goes johnson
three leafy
oh no they're shredding him
oh no he didn't
luca doncic is absolutely putting on a
show here
in the valley 27 points from
in the league this year doncic right
there
27 points from luca he's the one who's
creating the mismatch in the double team
and forcing the suns to scramble
church on the pass
by booker
89
and he's got 30.
um
just a step back 35 footer by luca it's
cameron johnson with seven
points
seven
and booker's old town here the front
that for three-time first team
player
doncic
with bridges on him shot clock is four
it is not right what luca is doing to
the phoenix suns doesn't matter who's
guarding them right
that's step back three going to his left
he just takes his time well certainly
the way
new orleans
pounded
the sons on the board
he just did a faroe
when he's been facing elimination
what
[Music]
i mean off bridges